everyone this is kevin from the chess
website common today we're going to be
looking at a tricky ending and that is
the rook verse the knight obviously in
this case there's no way for black to
win which is simply a knight but white
usually has a hard time winning a game
with rook and knight but we are going to
go over what white should do and how
black should defend now as you can tell
from this example if it's White's move Y
can simply move King to g2 and the
night's going to be lost there's no way
that I can move to get out of the way of
harm and he's going to be captured and
it's going to be a pretty easy in game
for white more times than not it's not
going to be that easy so we're going to
take a look at some other examples and
see just how hard it can be but by the
end of this you're going to know exactly
how to do it
let's go and take a look at another
example here and as you can see our work
is being attacked by the king now have
all these colors out here so you can
take a look if the knight is in one of
these red squares here around then
there's a great chance that you're gonna
win this this is really where you want
the night to be if his night is here you
can usually win if his knight is in the
yellow you have a good chance but not as
great as if it's in the red now if you
allow the knight to get into these
squares in the middle then the game for
the most part is going to be drawn
unless there's incorrect play by it
either the size so from here the rook is
being attacked by white a lot of times
you may someone see someone try to get
their rook out of harm's way by moving
something like ei trying to get his rook
out of the way saying that later on
he'll attack the knight this is actually
going to be a drawing game if Mike plays
correctly this is give me a drawing game
and white has lost his initiative and
the game itself he would have wanted now
he's going to draw so let's go ahead and
take a look at what white should have
done what white should have done and
what you need to think about in a rook
vers night in game is you want to limit
the squares that the knight can go to so
in this case our best move is just
simply rook to e3 you can already see
that we've taken away all the squares
that the Black Knight can go to a3 c3
and d2 even if the black King tries to
come and attack us again we can simply
move to b3
and we've taken away all the squares
that I can go to and we're attacking him
as well on the next move we're going to
take the knight and then it's simply a
king and rook in game which is much
easier than trying to figure out how to
win this right here is a clear win from
white after we take the knight so let's
go ahead and take a look at a few more
tables and see how we can take this rook
and Knight in game and turn it into a
win for white
let's go take a look at another example
here and go ahead it's White's move go
ahead and take a minute to see if in
your head you can figure out where white
should go so if you need to pause it
figure out where you think Y should go
the hill win here and I hope you came up
with the move rook to FA and what this
does that takes away all the squares
that the knight can go the knight can't
go to f7 can't go to f5 and it can't go
to rook to g8 so from here the black
king is going to move to d6 now take a
minute again and think about where you
think whites should move and hopefully
you came up with the simple move rook to
f6 forking the night the king is going
to have to move it and we can simply
take the night here on h6 and then it's
just simply a king and rook in game
first the King which is a pretty easy
win for white now if you thought about
something like King to g5 the black king
can simply come to East 7 attacking our
rook and this is actually going to be a
drawing game there's nothing white can
do if black plays correctly to win this
game so hopefully you're seeing it a
little bit clearer let's go ahead and
take a look at one more example and
hopefully that'll ingrain it a little
bit more into your brain
[Music]
let's go and take a look at this example
here take a minute and pause the video
if you want to and see where you think
white should move to make sure that he
has a winning game here and hopefully
you just came up with rook to d5
obviously right away the knight could
not come to c5 or a five because our
rook was attacking it but we want to
limit the squares he can go to and then
what scores he can go to we're attacking
it so he has to move our f8 and f6 and
it doesn't matter which one he moves to
now because then we can simply come to
rook to f5 and fork the knight here once
the King moves and we're going to take
the knight here so hopefully you guys
have enjoyed this hopefully you all have
learned something if you do come to an
end game and you see a rook and Knight
look at where the knight is in
relationship to the rest of the board
and if he is on the outer rim then more
than likely you're going to have a
winning in game so take this and if you
ever do come across it now you'll know
how to turn this slide advantage into a
victory if you have an RA please
subscribe and I'll see you guys next
video thanks for watching everybody
you